brenda s'achète une auto neuve
quelques mois plus tard problème de
moteur brenda donne la chance aux
concessionnaires et aux fabricants de
régler le problème mais c'est peine
perdue sa voiture jouet inciteront à
mère brenda porte plainte au programme
d'arbitrage pour les véhicules
automobiles du canada
le cavac au moins c'est gratuit le pav
ac agit comme un tribunal
il règle des différends au moyen d'un
arbitrage obligatoire un service offert
dans toutes les provinces canadiennes
loto de brenda doit respecter certains
critères notamment avoir moins de 4 ans
et comptait moins de 160 mille
kilomètres la sentence est sans appel
final est exécutoire
le pavage ne peut pas annuler le contrat
de vente de brenda mais il peut exiger
que son auto soit réparé et que ces
frais de réparation soient remboursés et
même que le fabricant rachète loto de
brenda le fin mot de l'histoire
pressez le citron des géants demande du
juge mais ça peut valoir la tête